attitudes of gratitude are all around us  sometimes a little nudge in that  direction though doesn't hurt that's  right well nate tanbaum has an example  in this week's what's cool at school  report  what's cool at school being thankful  some encouraging words from governor  steve sissellach were answered by  youngsters from cc ronaldo elementary  school who busted out their singing  skills to show them they got the message  we need to be thankful for the people  that we have around us because we're  really  really lucky when you think about it  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  oh  great job kids also the governor as you  saw there with the nevada national guard  honoring rano's principal michelle  crawford with an air force commendation  medal if you know something cool at  school let us know cool at school is  under the community tab on our website  8newsnow.com or just email us cool at  school at 8newsnow.com